bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
savouregarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir et un et deux 40 9 3 24
heures après le premier sur le projet de
loi de finances Elisabeth borne a coupé
court hier soir au débat parlementaire
en déclenchant un deuxième 49-3 cette
fois sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale le texte qui prévoit les
recettes de la Santé a donc été adoptée
sans vote nous verrons dans le détail
quel texte exactement scénario
prévisible mais qui pose quand même des
questions de fond pourquoi le
gouvernement et les oppositions ne
parviennent pas à sortir des jeux de
posture sommes-nous incapables de
changer de culture politique grand débat
dans un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau deux grands témoins ce soir pour
ausculter la qualité des débats dans
cette nouvelle assemblée de juristes
grand spécialiste de l'art oratoire qui
nous invite à réapprendre à débattre
sans céder à la tyrannie des réseaux
sociaux Bertrand Périer Guillaume
Prigent publie débattre comment nous
reparler chez Flammarion ils seront tous
les deux sur ce plateau dans la deuxième
partie enfin nous couvrons nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris le mot
de la semaine qui a choisi Mariette
darrigran c'est le mot colère les
archives de Brandon warrett sur les
grands débats de censure rester dans
l'histoire et puis Matthieu aux anneaux
du shift project gaz électricité et si
la météo plus clémente nous prémunissait
des coupures cet hiver voilà pour le
menu de Sévère ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
de 49,3 en moins d'une semaine les
Français voulaient obligés la majorité
et l'opposition à s'entendre et bien
c'est raté on va se pencher ce soir sur
ce jeu de dupe à l'oeuvre dans
l'hémicyclier hier soir vous verrez ce
deuxième 49-3 sur la partie recette du
budget de la Sécurité sociale déclenchée
hier soir interroge la façon de
gouverner mais aussi la façon de
s'opposer bonsoir et bienvenue
Christopher weisberg bienvenue à vous
vous êtes député renaissance des
Français établis en Amérique du Nord la
majorité en très très petit nombre hier
soir sur des bancs de l'hémicier que
vous expliquerez pourquoi bonsoir Jérôme
Guedj bienvenue à vous député socialiste
de l'Essonne membres de la nupesse le
budget de la Sécu prévoit 100 milliards
de plus pour la santé l'hôpital ce n'est
pas rien vous nous direz pourquoi malgré
cela vous vous y êtes opposé bonsoir
Elsa bonsoir Elsa monding gavage
journaliste politique et parlementaire à
la rédaction LCP qui suit attentivement
tous ces débats dont celui d'hier soir
et puis l'économiste de la santé
Frédéric bizard va nous rejoindre dans
un tout petit instant le temps pour
Stéphane de nous planter le décor acte
de scène 2 que s'est-il passé hier soir
dans l'hémicycle si j'ai bien compris au
théâtre ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
Elsa bonsoir Monsieur si j'ai bien
compris ce soir alors si j'ai bien
compris Myriam depuis que l'assemblée
est revenu au centre du jeu politique il
y a des tas de journalistes qui s'y
intéressent qui ne s'y intéressait pas
jusqu'à donc ils sont à la fois étonnés
et unanime ils ont tous la même
impression ils se disent mais les débats
l'assemblée ça sonne un peu faux on
dirait du théâtre regardez c'est pas
tous les jours que le point est
Médiapart on embrasse Franz Olivier
Giesbert on fait une petite bise every
Plenel ils sont d'accord aujourd'hui
mais c'est pareil regardez l'humain les
communistes et L'Express les libéraux
pareil il trouve que tout ça ressemble
un peu à une comédie c'est vrai que hier
le deuxième 49-3 utilisé par Elisabeth
borne a suscité beaucoup de remous dans
l'hémicycle justement est très théâtrale
c'est toujours la même mise en scène
toujours la même posture regardez
comment ça s'est passé quand la Première
ministre a annoncé le 49-3
engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la
toujours le même jeu de scène
l'opposition quitte l'hémicycle le
député contre il est indigné
il claque le public là il quitte
l'hémicycle donc la majorité sont
vraiment de conviction ils applaudissent
un peu histoire de jouer leur rôle aussi
voilà il soutiennent un petit peu la
première ministre tout ça c'est du
spectacle mais justement c'est ce qui
finit par réserver la nuit pêche on est
normalement pas dans une pièce de
théâtre et pourtant Cyrielle Chapuis
finalement on est face à un gouvernement
qui considère la démocratie comme une
pièce de théâtre nous refusons d'en être
un de ces acteurs oui on dénonce la
pièce en même temps la nuit pêche a joué
son rôle jusqu'au bout ils ont été
déposés une motion de censure qui a peu
de chances d'être adopté mon frère pour
la forme voilà pour le pour le geste
c'est vrai qu'en cas 49 3 l'opposition
les députés de l'opposition sont dans un
rôle de spectateur et pas forcément
regardez hier je parle à côté de Jérôme
Guedj la nuit a joué en proposant des
abonnements je crois que c'est un
abonnement communiste pour augmenter le
budget de la Sécu 2023
sont proposés une augmentation d'un
milliard on va dire pour les hôpitaux
donc voilà même s'il y a une majorité de
députés qui s'est prononcée hier en
faveur de cette augmentation du budget
pour le gouvernement peu importe puisque
au bout du compte il suffit qu'ils
sortent le 49-3 pour annuler tout ça
donc on écoute Jérôme bien ce qui était
plus en colère hier qu'aujourd'hui vous
verrez quand nous faisons cette
proposition de rajouter un milliard et
demi d'euros que nous obtenons gain de
cause que nous avons une majorité alors
eux-mêmes suppriment leur propre article
qui prévoyait cette disposition on est
vraiment c'est ubuesque
ubuesque comme au théâtre voilà le
personnage du père Rubus c'est l'ivresse
du pouvoir selon la nups alors pourtant
le gouvernement je l'écoute depuis ces
quelques semaines il est toujours ouvert
au compromis non mais oui mais ça c'est
le titre du one man show de Gabriella
c'est vive le compromis spectacle
extraordinaire il y a pire si vous
voulez que d'assister un one man show de
Gabriel Attal c'est quand même un garçon
très doué hier comment il a réussi à
reprocher en ORL en l'occurrence de ne
pas participer au débat de ne pas faire
l'effort d'écrire un amendement l'écoute
vous auriez la possibilité de faire des
propositions différentes sur l'année
2022 de dire il faudrait mettre plus sur
tel branche moins sur tel branche pour
essayer de faire changer la politique
mais vous venez juste pour voter contre
vous venez juste pour voter contre et
pour bloquer donc ça limite quand même
ça limite quand même les possibilités
débat il est doué il y a pas de doute
même Marine Le Pen elle a dit Monsieur
Attal vous avez 1000 talents sauf que à
quoi bon déposer des amendements quand
on sait qu'ils seront balayés par le
49-3 la réponse de Marine Le Pen si vous
voulez le dégainer la Constitution vous
en donne le droit vous appelez la
première ministre elle arrive elle
dégaine l'article 49-3 mais on c'est pas
la peine de surjouer l'indignation oui
c'est quand même assez bien envoyé on
peut pas non plus le nier donc c'est
vrai que quand on sort le 49-3 on se dit
mais finalement mais à quoi bon débattre
et d'ailleurs le pire peut-être c'est
que même les députés de la majorité
l'ont bien compris ils sont dit à quoi
bon venir dans l'hémicycle participer à
un vote puisque à la fin de toute façon
on aura le 49-3 qui va faire que le
texte qui sera adopté sera celui de la
majorité et c'est ce qu'a fait remarquer
un député LR Thibault Bazin il vous
appartient aussi de mobiliser les 240
députés de la majorité parce que là vous
pourriez faire passer aussi cet article
2 il vous reste quelques minutes pour le
faire c'est votre responsabilité merci
vous voyez même la majorité ne veut plus
participer à cette pièce de théâtre
attention là il y a 49-3 il y aura pas
toujours le 49-3 ça sera bientôt plus
animé plus équilibré des débats
l'assemblés
ce soir très bon week-end à vous
Stéphane parce que c'est pas toujours le
cas c'est vrai Christopher weisberg
c'est un jeu de dupe c'est très bien
résumé par par Stéphane blackovski vous
pensez vraiment les Français attendaient
ça en donnant la majorité absolue à
aucun des groupes est-ce que est-ce que
vous êtes pas un peu
entre ça du mandat qui vous a été donné
c'est un jeu de Nupe parce que soyons
très clair des des amendements un
milliard 300 millions dans un budget ça
n'a jamais été fait je n'existe pas en
fait il y a des amendements on l'a vu
cet été à 50 millions d'euros certes
mais un milliard 300 millions d'euros
c'est pas possible ça rend bah non c'est
pas possible enfin ça n'a c'est pas le
jeu de nos institutions vous avez
d'ailleurs très bien dit que est-ce que
ça va être comme tout le temps comme ça
ça va pas être tout le temps comme ça
mais sur le budget on le sait depuis le
début on aura un enjeu de vote les
oppositions étaient très claires dès le
début elles ont dit à la fin on va pas
les textes on a quand même été jusqu'au
bout on a eu un travail en commission
vous avez dit qu'il y avait pas beaucoup
de collègues alors justement moi j'étais
là politique la politique de la chaise
vide on veut essayer de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé est-ce que c'est Aurore
berger qui vous a dit très clairement
allez-y rentrez en circonscription il y
aura un 49-3 vous étiez entre 40 et 50
pour un groupe Renaissance qui de 170
députés déjà en général quand on dit
quelque chose dans un groupe on le sait
déjà parce que maintenant avec Twitter
tout sort et si jamais la présidente de
groupe a dit ne venez pas en fait c'est
pire parce que ils sont ils sont pas
venus ils ont estimé c'était pas
important le budget de la Sécu c'est
pire mais on était là enfin on était là
on est battu c'est normal on est on est
on est minoritaire
que vous êtes déjà lassés est-ce que
vous êtes fatigué enfin je veux dire moi
j'étais là encore une fois je suis pas
membre de la commission d'affaires
sociales et j'étais là
traditionnellement sur ce genre de texte
il y a toujours la commission compétente
qui est présente ils étaient là ils
étaient tous là il y avait des députés
qui étaient présents et on est et moi
j'étais présent c'est la deuxième
semaine de débat après le PLF la semaine
dernière et les gens étaient aussi
présents il y a des travaux en
commission partout enfin je veux dire
c'est pas sur LCP qu'on va refaire le
débat sur le fait que quand il y a pas
et tout l'ensemble des députés c'est pas
parce que les députés sont fatigués ou
ne veulent pas travailler on sait très
bien qu'il y a plein de choses qui se
passent dans l'assemblée et que on peut
pas mobiliser l'ensemble vous avez tout
à fait raison mais 149 il y a eu un très
très gros problème parce que vous étiez
minoritaire ça vaut le coup vous le
consommez donc vous l'avez anticipé
nous aurions un problème institutionnel
dans ce pays heureusement on a 43 et je
rappelle vous l'aurez pas sur tous les
textes vous savez utiliser que pour les
textes budgétaires et une seule fois sur
un texte donc il va falloir apprendre à
faire on va parler le fameux compromis
qui n'a pas du tout Jérôme Guedj est-ce
qu'il y a pas
un tout de même avec ses 49,3
répétitions au fond échec peut-être du
gouvernement à convaincre mais échec
aussi des oppositions à se montrer
constructive ah mais c'est vous qui le
dites parce que moi très sincèrement je
l'ai dit d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle
hier j'ai dit moi j'étais prêt à ne pas
voter contre ce pull FSS j'aime trop la
sécurité sociale je considère qu'il y a
trop d'enjeux sur l'hôpital sur la santé
sur les maisons de retraite sur le grand
âge pour ne pas jouer sincèrement le jeu
et moi je l'ai joué en commission j'ai
juste vous donner des chiffres en
commission il y a eu 670 amendements qui
ont été déposés par votre groupe
majoritaire par les oppositions etc moi
personnellement avec mon groupe j'en ai
déposé 190 voilà sur ces 670 amendements
qui ont été déposés il y en a 67 qui ont
été acceptés sur ces 67
qui ont été acceptés il y en a une
petite vingtaine qui viennent des
différentes des différentes oppositions
nous socialistes on a réussi à en faire
passer 5 et les cinq qu'on a réussi à
faire passer je suis très content mais
il change pas la face du système est-ce
que vous nous dites est assez terrible
en disant on peut pas faire des
amendements qui ont une ampleur
significative ah bon donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas d'autres textes possibles
que celui que vous avez proposé quand je
dépose un amendement pour dire le
gouvernement propose de créer 3000
postes supplémentaires dans les maisons
de retraite en 2023 alors qui s'est
engagé dans son discours de politique
générale à en faire 50 000 sur la durée
du quinquennat c'est-à-dire 10000 par an
donc moi je fais un amendement pour dire
faisons les 10000 parents qui étaient
envisagés on me dit non
vous voyez bien que attendez on n'est
pas dans la construction on n'est pas
dans la co-construction de vous dire que
pour pour cet argent là vous avez pris
sur la médecine de ville parce que vous
savez très bien vous n'avez pas d'autres
moyens que de le faire
il faut expliquer que député dans le cas
d'un débat ne peut pas créer de dépenses
nouvelles c'est bien on peut on peut
avoir un point d'explication là-dessus
évidemment c'est le principe principale
c'est le grand différence avec encore
une fois d'autres régimes comme le
régime américain ou quand on fait un
amendement budgétaire on peut proposer
une vraie dépense ici on est toujours
contrarié par le fait qu'il faut si je
peux me permettre parce que c'est super
important c'est que dans le même temps
on a proposé des amendements pour
augmenter des dépenses comme celui que
je viens de décrire là mais on a aussi
proposé des amendements pour créer des
recettes nouvelles et on a en face de
nous dit tous les cas je vais vous dire
moi j'ai dit ça va être drôle parce que
vous disiez on peut pas faire des
amendements à un milliard moi j'ai fait
un amendement pour revenir sur des
exonérations de cotisations sociales
donc qui rapporte un milliard d'euros à
la collectivité parce que bon on va pas
rentrer dans les détails mais c'était le
pack de compétitivité de François
Hollande on a fait des exonérations de
cotisations sociales je veux dire c'est
assez drôle parce que dommage on n'a pas
pu aller dans l'hémicycle mais cet
amendement le mien a été repris
quasiment à l'identique vous savez par
qui par 28 députés du groupe Renaissance
même chez vous vous avez un président de
la commission des lois un commissaire
des affaires sociales comme Marc
ferrachi qui fait une proposition pour
dégager des ressources supplémentaires
parce que si on fait on supprime ces
exonérations c'est donc plus d'argent
qui rentre dans les caisses de la
Sécurité sociale et qui permettent de
financer ses dépenses donc on avait
l'espace pour faire ce compromis on
avait la possibilité soit on crée des
recettes nouvelles vous dites on veut
pas de recette nouvelle à un moment si
on veut améliorer toute une série de
politiques sociales il va bien falloir
des recettes ou alors revenir sur des
exonérations et bien quand on joue on
joue sincèrement le jeu vous nous dites
non il y a pas d'autre solution que ça
et ben vous voyez bien qu'à la fin vous
êtes dans l'impasse du 49-3 on va
essayer d'y revenir et de voir des
choses les unes après les autres parce
que c'est vrai que cet amendement est
important et il y a des soutien dans
votre camp sur cet amendement elles a
mon Agava vous qui regardez ça depuis
voilà depuis la Chaîne parlementaire
avec beaucoup de précisions doubles
échec je deuses ou on est dans le cas de
budgétaire des choses seront différentes
après on a beaucoup parlé de jeudi de
mise en scène puisque il faut quand même
rappeler que le budget c'est pas un
texte comme les autres le budget c'est
un texte qui est très politique et même
si là vous dites j'aurais pu voter un
budget non généralement les oppositions
j'aurais pu ne pas voter contre
si le texte va dans l'autre sens de
l'intérêt général je vote pas pour parce
que je suis pas dans la majorité
on a changé d'air là il y a une nouvelle
majorité c'est une nouvelle donne
politique pourquoi un député de
l'opposition resterait campé sur les dés
qu'on peut pas voter pour un budget au
nom de quoi c'est écrit nulle part ça
non mais c'est aussi une forme de
tradition politique je viens de vous
dire c'est déjà quelque chose de
significatif s'abstenir sur un texte de
la majorité c'est dire écoutez ça va
dans la bonne direction parce qu'on y a
trouvé telle ou point intéressant le
jour où on votera pour c'est parce qu'on
aura le sentiment que la totalité des
dispositions qui figure sont les bonnes
or dans ce pdfss il y avait certaines
sur lesquelles j'étais en totale des
accords mais bon déjà dire qu'on est
prêt à s'abstenir mais même ça il y a
pas la recherche de ce compromis pour le
faire alors justement je reviens juste
mais c'est vrai que j'explique parce que
pour les téléspectateurs c'est peut-être
important effectivement si on vote pour
un budget c'est qu'on fait partie de la
majorité donc on traditionnellement
effectivement et ça c'est pas près de
changer a priori on reste sur cette
position là donc imaginez dès le départ
qui puisse y avoir des députés des
oppositions qui votent pour le budget
pour beaucoup de journalistes c'était
une fable ensuite il y a autre chose
c'est que je caricature un peu mais à
droite de l'hémicycle on dit que le
gouvernement laisse complètement filer
la dette à gauche de l'hémicycle on dit
qu'il présente un budget d'austérité
c'est quoi un compromis alors avec la
droite et la gauche c'est dire pour
faire plaisir à la droite en fait c'est
antinomique donc le compromis avec une
opposition et possible avec des
oppositions qui ont des points de vue si
différents et ça le gouv comme on l'a
dit ça n'aurait pas de sens ça n'aurait
pas de dire qu'on n'est pas bloc contre
bloc on a quatre blocs exactement c'est
multibloc voilà et c'est très
intéressant depuis dès le début on nous
vante le compromis on nous vante les
dialogues de Bercy sauf qu'en fait on
veut mettre des ronds dans des carrés en
disant vous pouvez proposer tout ce que
vous voulez mais faut pas que ça coûte
de l'argent il faut pas taxer plus en
fait finalement on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement le 49-3 c'était la
seule issue et ça on savait depuis le
début d'où cette impression qu'on a
un éditorial
mais je redis juste un point évidemment
que le 49-3 c'est une fatalité
obligatoire dans ce contexte là
d'ailleurs vous le savez très bien parce
que Michel Rocard il a utilisé 28 fois
et pourtant c'était un premier de gauche
qui a fait le RMI à son époque donc au
fond on sait très bien que dans ce
contexte avec 4 blocs on ne peut pas
arriver à Adil et moi je pense qu'on a
joué le jeu jusqu'au bout on aurait pu
dire dès le début on n'aura pas de
compromis et on le fera on a essayé sur
le fond du texte et je salue Frédéric
bizarre bonsoir vous êtes économiste de
la santé avant de voir précisément ce
qu'il y a dans ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale une petite séquence vous soir
dans l'hémicycle en direct si j'ose dire
Jérôme Guedj Gabriel Gabriel Attal que
vous connaissez bien puisque vous étiez
tous les deux sous François Hollande
vous députez socialiste en 2012 lui
conseiller politique au cabinet
d'administes de la santé de l'époque qui
s'appelait Marisol Touraine Il vous
disait ceci regardez il se trouve qu'on
a tous les deux été impliqués à des
degrés différents et à des places
différentes dans le quinquennat de
François Hollande et la réalité c'est
que vous le savez de tel niveau de
dépenses pour notre système de santé on
en aurait rêvé à l'époque on en aurait
rêvé à l'époque on était au Parti
socialiste mais évidemment c'est inédit
Jérôme Guedes qu'est-ce que vous
répondez 100 milliards de dépenses de
l'État supplémentaire pour l'hôpital
pour la santé
si c'était 100 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires pour l'hôpital
je l'aurais voté trois fois ce plfs +
3,7 % de longue dame est plus 4,1
l'effort à l'hôpital ça correspond à
quand même un effort supplémentaire
d'euros juste pour avoir des ordres de
grandeur pour savoir de quoi on parle
mais non non les ordres de grandeur sur
la dépense hospitalière c'est en gros
100 milliards d'euros le montant total
de la dépense hospitalière donc quand on
y ajoute
3,5
à 8 milliards supplémentaires
on va pas le contester le seul problème
sur cette situation je vais répondre
j'ai la même chose que j'ai dit
hier dans l'hémicycle c'est qu'on a une
augmentation en pourcentage de cet
objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie qui est l'ensemble
de la dépense que la collectivité mais
au service de toutes les politiques de
santé
l'ONDAM il progresse de 3,7%. c'est vrai
que jamais un nom d'âme depuis que les
PLFSS existent c'est-à-dire depuis 1996
n'a été aussi importante mais il y a un
mais jamais l'ONDAM le montant de la
dame n'a été inférieur à l'inflation
c'est la première fois qu'on a un
montant de lambdame or l'inflation elle
rogne elle rogne les marges de manœuvre
déstructures notamment hospitalières des
ehpads qui sont financés pour partie et
donc on a voilà une différence
d'appréciation global et c'est donc 7
milliards Frédéric bizarre qu'est-ce que
vous dites c'est pas suffisant on sait
qu'il faut augmenter les soignants on
sait que l'hôpital va mal les EHPAD sont
en crise il y a toute une série de
revalorisation à faire 7 milliards on
est d'accord sur ce chiffre de plus
sachant qu'on a une inflation à 6 c'est
en deçà de ce qu'il faut faire ou pas
je crois pas que ça soit une question
que ça soit suffisant pas suffisant
c'est la prise de conscience qu'on est à
la fin d'un cycle qui est ce modèle
social créé en 1945 dans un monde qui a
radicalement changé d'accord si on prend
la santé dans cette triple transition
démographique épidémiologique
technologique le contexte a radicalement
changé et en fait on essaie toujours de
conserver ce qui a été créé avant cette
transition avant changement je crois
président de la République actuelle a
été élu sur la conviction qui qu'on
arrivait dans un nouveau monde qui a été
assez convaincante et donc il fallait
l'adapter la société bon sauf que
finalement on adapte pas grand chose en
tout cas pas le modèle social donc à la
fois vous on est en train de s'échapper
sur des chiffres
je pense pas qu'il y a un seul député
qui lise l'intégralité de ce document
qu'elle appelle FSS peut-être mon voisin
mais qui mais parce que il est juste il
est juste inaccessible il est
inaccessible
purement techno c'est purement techno
c'est-à-dire que vous avez même pas une
page à l'entrée pour présenter la
politique sociale de ce gouvernement
comme de s'élever le cas depuis 27 ans
donc c'est inaccessible ce qui pense
quand même on Éva plus lisible dans un
projet sur la santé
c'est un semblant de démocratie que l'on
fait où on dit les ordonnances JP on dit
bon il faut quand même faire voter et
c'est pas du tout le problème actuel
politique c'est le l'idée c'était de
dire il faut quand même rendre ce
système plus démocratique comme si
d'ailleurs la sécurité sociale n'était
pas démocratique puisque c'est une
institution qui a été pensée pour être
démocratique c'était d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus démocratique du temps de la vraie
sécu autonome de l'État mais comme on a
quasi est attisé la sécu qu'on a mis
très dépendante de l'État on a dit bon
ben l'État c'est quelque chose quelque
chose de démocratique et donc on va une
fois par an on va créer un grand débat
démocratique sur le modèle social
désolé voilà où on en est aujourd'hui il
y a aucun débat sur le fond on met juste
les chiffres non mais c'est pas propre à
vous c'est pas pop c'est depuis 25 ans
bon alors ce PLFSS peut en parler est-ce
qu'il est suffisant est-ce qu'il est
sincère comme on est sur les choses je
pense que il y a une tendance comme à
chaque fois d'essayer d'habiller ce
PLFSS pour que après elle pose covid
pour qui est un semblant de retour à la
normale et qu'on se dise globalement le
trou de la Sécu est résorbé et les
choses vont bien bon donc on surestime
les recettes un point de croissance en
2023 enfin il y a pas un économiste qui
peut vous soutenir ça pour une
institution économique
ensuite est-ce qu'il y a une
transformation des dépenses on sentait
oui oui bien sûr quand vous êtes à 10
points d'inflation sur 2022 2023 et que
vous augmentez la médecine de ville de
2,1 avec tous les besoins que l'on a
parce que si on veut alléger la charge
hospitalière donc faire que l'hôpital
aille moins mal je suis désolé il faut
investir et ben voilà n'y sont pas d'une
dizaine de milliards à minimum
on va essayer de regarder dans ce gros
document
ultra techno si j'ai bien compris
quelques mesures qui racontent un tout
petit peu quelles sont les priorités de
ce gouvernement en matière de santé et
d'hôpital les détails avec Clément mec
à part de notre budget consacré à la
prévention et deux fois plus faible que
chez nos voisins pour rattraper ce
retard le ministre de la Santé met en
place des bilans de santé 100%
remboursés à trois âges clés de la vie
20-25 ans 40 45 ans et 60 65 ans au
volley prévention également la pilule du
lendemain sera désormais gratuité sans
ordonnance pour toutes les femmes et à
tous les âges remboursement à 100%
également du dépistage des infections
sexuellement transmissibles jusqu'à 26
ans
une quatrième année d'internat en
médecine générale va être créée pour
s'attaquer aux problèmes des déserts
médicaux durant cette année les internes
effectueront des stages hors hôpital en
priorité dans les déserts le
gouvernement prévoit aussi d'élargir les
permanences de garde le soir et les
week-end à d'autres professions de santé
chirurgien dentiste sage-femme et
infirmier seront désormais concernés
c'est une mesure qui fait débat les
arrêts de travail prescrits en
téléconsultation ne seront plus
remboursés sauf s'ils sont prescrits par
le médecin traitant ou par un médecin vu
par le patient au cours des 12 derniers
mois autre mesure destinées à lutter
contre la fraude les prestations
sociales ne pourront plus être versées
sur des comptes bancaires situés en
dehors de l'Europe à compter de 2024
c'est une décision attendue par beaucoup
d'hôpitaux publics pour lutter contre
les mercenaires de la santé les jeunes
soignants n'auront plus le droit de
travailler en intérim à leur sortie
d'école cette mesure vient s'ajouter au
plafonnement de la rémunération des
médecins intérimaires un plafonnement
qui entrera en vigueur au printemps
prochain
quand on regarde tout ça la prévention
des je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
bizarre le grand perdant du 49.3 c'est
qu'on n'a pas eu qu'on n'aura pas un
débat global sur les priorités des
politiques sociales il y en avait
quelques-unes qui figurent dans le très
bon la très bonne synthèse que vous
venez faire mais qui sont un peu vous
voyez un catalogue à la préférence
surtout ces sujets on avait fait des
propositions
sur la prévention en commission j'ai
voté pour ces dispositions pour la
prévention 100% remboursés les
consultations
on a même fait voter des amendements
pour préciser le contenu et François
Brown avait dit on va reprendre les
amendements de Monsieur Guedj ou du
groupe socialiste ou d'autres etc qui
précisaient par exemple notamment pour
les personnes malades de cancer que le
consultation sont un peu plus spécifique
sur les la santé sexuelle
gratuite bonne chose
incontestablement sauf que le débat il
s'organise que sur la liste de ces
quelques mesures que le Gouvernement a
mis en place on n'a pas une réflexion
globale sur le système de santé je vous
prends qu'un seul exemple pour le sujet
qui me tient à cœur on demande depuis
des années y compris des députés du
groupe Renaissance une loi grand âge et
autonomie le gouvernement nous avait dit
on va mettre les mesures dans le PLFSS
il y en a pas dans le PLFSS et donc on
était même pas en capacité de faire des
faire des propositions ce qui nous
manque c'est une proposition que fait
l'Institut santé c'est une loi
d'orientation et de programmation plus
réelle sur qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
c'est quoi les objectifs de santé
publique qu'on peut mettre en place et
après le plfs c'est juste les moyens je
vous vois vous hocher de la tête vous
êtes d'accord avec Jérôme moi je suis
sur l'autonomie qui est d'ailleurs quand
même une troisième branche qu'on a
ouvert cinquième branche qu'on a ouvert
l'année dernière juste avant laquelle
vous étiez d'ailleurs attaché et je
pense que vous pouvez remarquer qu'on
l'a fait et que ça c'est une chose
politique maintenant il faut le financer
le débat d'ailleurs sur la retraite
aborde aussi cette question l'ensemble
des méthodes stratégique d'ensemble sur
la santé
annuel pour se fixer des objectifs à
long terme je suis assez d'accord sur ce
point là franchement on se rejoint et je
suis d'accord que c'est très frustrant
franchement moi je suis pas membre de la
commission d'affaires sociales mais
quand on est dans cette émission au fond
c'est quand même un jeu de dupe chacun
est dans et chacun est dans une logique
mais bien sûr quand on propose des
amendements à un milliard 300 millions
on sait très bien que c'est d'entendre
un spécialiste question de santé vous
dire le compte n'ayez pas de fait
puisque l'inflation est supérieure
il y a une inflation mais enfin ça c'est
un problème qu'on va voir absolument
toutes les politiques publiques on a un
problème d'inflation et on essaye quand
même de maintenir l'inflation à un
niveau qui est beaucoup moins important
que dans pas mal de pays donc il y a
quand même un travail là dessus j'ai
conscience que quand ce que vous dites
je crois que c'est quelque chose que
chacun ressent quand on vit dans ce pays
on a l'impression que notre système de
santé est à la fois quelque chose
d'extraordinairement généreux fondé sur
une solidarité et que il a une ambition
très forte et que depuis des années mais
mettons-nous d'accord ça fait ça fait
plus de 30 ans qu'on a qu'on a ce
problème ce sentiment de désert médicaux
pendant le Ségur de la santé on a déjà
essayé d'adresser ce problème les moyens
qui ont été mis moi j'ai vu dans des
départements ruraux comme dans la Nièvre
à Cosne-sur-Loire des hôpitaux qui
n'existaient plus qui vont être
réinstallés dans l'Yonne a été des
centaines de millions d'euros dans une
région que je connais bien il y a eu cet
effort là mais pour autant de façon
systémique il y a un problème de
financement et il y a un problème de
comment on arrive à atteindre cette
ambition là où moi je franchement je
jette pas la pierre au parlementaire de
de quand même Infiné de faire quelque
chose qui qui n'arrange pas le système
parce que la prévention ça se fait pas
avec des consultations médicales la
prévention c'est pas simplement le on va
voir le médecin tous les 20 ans en plus
on démarre à 25 ans ou c'est déjà trop
tard enfin bon on pourra discuter puis
je croyais qu'il fallait sortir du
paiement à l'acte et en fait on paie à
l'acte ce qui est vraiment la dernière
des choses à faire c'est de payer à
l'acte de la prévention bon donc ça se
paye à la capitation c'est enfin on sait
mais donc on néglige en fait tous les
basiques des choses donc ça ne peut pas
marcher ça peux pas marcher mais je
jette pas la pierre parce que là vous
êtes que sur un des trois leviers pour
restructurer le système et le premier
c'est la gouvernance notre système
dysfonctionne c'est comme tout
organisation qui dysfonctionne parce que
ceux qui pilote sont pas les bons
d'accord l'État a pris tout le pouvoir
sur la sécu sur les les soignants
qui devrait être les pilotes aujourd'hui
il faut privilégier
l'état il doit être il doit être
s'occuper de la stratégie du long terme
et puis de ce qu'on peut appeler du
régalien en santé de la santé publique
faudrait la population et puis il doit
être délégué ce que ce qu'est le
fondement acquis à une structure
démocratique qui quelle est la structure
démocratique dans le système la séquence
c'est la sécurité sociale ou alors on va
au bout de privatisation on fait un vrai
système manager on nationalise une
grande partie du système de santé et
puis donc oui on met un peu de cohérence
ce système il est incohérent parce qu'on
l'a un peu étatisé puis on a un peu
americanisé avec ses réseaux de soins
dans les dans le dentaire et dans le
truc et donc on a un système qui qui
dysfonctionne à cause de ça alors que
monsieur l'a dit et il a raison il y a
un paradoxe entre cette crise la plus
profonde de son histoire et une
abondance de ressources en termes de
qualité nous nous avons toujours des
professionnels de santé parmi les
meilleurs au monde où nous avons des
grandes institutions des sociétés
savantes nous avons des grandes facultés
de médecine monte pas donc il faut quand
même se poser la question quand est-ce
qu'on va essayer de remettre sur les
bons rails le système a dérailler pour
la raison que je vais dire c'est que
l'environnement a changé donc quand vous
quand vous échapper sur le financement
vous n'utilisez qu'un des leviers
l'autre il y a la gouvernance et puis
l'organisation du système le seul
service public qui existe dans le
système service public hospitalier parce
que le système repose sur les
ordonnances de Bray où on a dit c'est
l'hôpital public alors et bien partons
territoire et des besoins parce que il y
a pas que le fait que on n'est qu'une
vision court terme avec ce budget c'est
que le budget ne part que de l'offre
vous vous avez une enveloppe pour
l'hôpital et pas des besoins ce que tu
as un petit peu gênant donc oui on est
très loin de vous écouter Frédéric
bizarre mais là ça demanderait à un
grand débat parce que vous nous faites
un panorama dans l'émission d'ensemble
avec une hauteur de vue une perspective
qui malheureusement ne pourront pas être
trouvé toutes les réponses ici on va
revenir au débat parlementaire Elsa à un
instant il y a deux amendements on
voulait mettre la lumière pour noter les
spectateurs sur ces deux amendements qui
ont la particularité d'être soutenu par
la majorité une partie des députés
Renaissance et pourtant non retenu dans
ce projet de loi final oui exactement
alors il y en a un qui sera certainement
discuté après c'est vrai que les députés
de la majorité ont tendance à voilà
prendre leur liberté n'hésite pas à dire
quand ils sont contre les villes du
gouvernement le début d'une fronde voilà
moi j'ai lu ces deux amants et je débute
au gouvernement fallait pas dans la
bonne direction alors je vous parle de
deux amendements comme ça ça vous
donnera l'occasion de d'en parler il y
en a un on en a parlé pour lutter contre
les fraudes le gouvernement veut arrêter
de rembourser les arrêts de travail qui
sont délivrés lorsqu'on fait une
consultation avec un médecin qu'on ne
connaît pas soit qui n'est pas notre
médecin traitant soit un médecin qu'on a
pas vu depuis un an ça il y a des
députés de la majorité une grosse
dizaine ils ont déposé un abonnement
pour dire oui mais dans les déserts
médicaux c'est grave parce que les gens
parfois n'ont pas le choix que la
téléconsultation c'est l'unique moyen
d'avoir un arrêt maladie de consulter un
médecin au ministère de la Santé pour
l'instant nous dit que le Gouvernement
est défavorable pourquoi parce que il a
un certain nombre de données qui lui
poussent à croire que ce n'est pas dans
les déserts médicaux que ces choses ont
lieu qu'il y a parfois des multiples
connexions ont été les consulte trois
quatre médecins d'affilée donc on
imagine que c'est Infiné pour aboutir à
un arrêt de travail et ça le
gouvernement n'en a pas voulu puisque le
49,3 il faut le réexpliquer
systématiquement c'est pas une évidence
pour tout le monde c'est le gouvernement
qui décide qu'il y a dans le texte final
deuxième amendement il me reste très peu
de temps oui sur les exonérations mais
c'est qui était aussi un amendement de
gauche qui est poussé par une trentaine
de députés
par une trentaine de députés certaines
entreprises elles ont des exonérations
de cotisation ils veulent les supprimer
pour les eaux salaires en disant on
supprime dans certains nombre d'impôts
pour les grandes sociétés comme la CVAE
il est temps aussi de montrer bien qu'on
s'attaque un petit peu au porte-monnaies
dans la volonté de justice sociale de
symboles également vous soutenir ces
deux amendements vous regrettez qu'il
n'ait pas été retenu vous aurez le mot
de la fin Christopher
parce que peut-être qu'on aurait pu
avoir une majorité et puis si j'ai bien
compris puisque le 49-3 fait que le
gouvernement a proposé un texte et
pouvait aller picorer les amendements
qui ont débattu pas débattu et si j'ai
bien compris ces deux-là ne sont pas
dans le texte définitif est-ce que ces
amendements ont encore un avenir puisque
vous devez la majorité j'ai pas le texte
final sur le PLFSS sur le PLF on a un
texte final sur le PLFSS c'est pas le
cas donc
beaucoup est pris alors on en reparlera
la prochaine fois d'un mot vous voulez
qu'on soit vraiment brièvement sur les
cotisations sociales au fond déjà à
l'époque quand la fronde a eu lieu au
Parti socialiste c'était un des sujets
c'est ce qu'on exode les entreprises par
rapport à notre modèle social et à
l'époque il y avait déjà eu un débat
dans un débardeur
je vous propose de revenir rapidement
sur LCP parce que quelque chose me dit
que le débat n'est pas Clo merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Elsa Frédéric
bizarre on va voir votre dernier livre
s'afficher à l'écran dans un tout petit
instant si on régit Frédéric bizard
dites-le nous peut-être comme ça
l'autonomie solidaire en santé voilà
l'autonomie solidaire en santé et c'est
aux éditions Michalon voilà tout est dit
merci à vous on va à présent accueillir
nos deux grands témoins deux hommes de
droit et deux hommes de verbes cela fait
des années qu'il travaille à
démocratiser l'art oratoire
l'apprentissage de la prise de parole en
ils sont à l'origine du grand oral sur
France 2 notamment il publie ensemble
débattre comment nous reparler chez
Flammarion que penses-tu alors des
débats parlementaires dans cette
nouvelle Assemblée Bertrand Périer et
Guillaume Préjean de rejoignent juste
après l'invitation de Marco première
regardez
si on vous invite Bertrand Perrier et
Guillaume Prigent c'est pour parler de
notre façon de débattre comment
retrouver le goût des joues oratoires
sans pour autant tomber dans la culture
du buzz et du clash c'est la question
que vous posez dans votre livre et ça
tombe bien parce qu'ici à l'Assemblée
nationale ça débat mais parfois ça
dérape aussi et sa place Monsieur le
Maire vous avez travaillé il fut un
temps pour Dominique de Villepin qui
avait dénoncé la lâcheté de ceux qui
refusent de défendre les intérêts de la
France aujourd'hui le lâche c'est vous
vous continuez à invectiver l'assemblée
et à invectiver la présidence si c'est
ce que vous faites honnêtement je ne
comprends plus rien
Bertrand Périer Guillaume Prigent vous
avez en commun l'éloquence l'art de
toucher et de persuader par le discours
vous en avez d'ailleurs fait votre
métier Bertrand Perrier ancien timide
mais aujourd'hui avocat au Conseil
d'État et à la Cour de cassation quant à
vous Guillaume Prigent vous enseignez
l'éloquence à Sciences Po et à l'École
de guerre dans vos livres vous parlez
chacun à votre manière de laboratoire la
parole au coeur de toutes les attentions
surtout quand il faut débattre j'ai dit
mille fois que débattre c'était le
contraire de se battre et que un peu
plus de débats c'était un peu moins de
violence plus de discussions dans une
France sous le débat est en mauvaise
santé dites-vous en cause les invectives
sur les plateaux de télévision à mais
Madame Le Pen je suis ou encore les
excès de l'anonymat sur les réseaux
sociaux sans oublier la désinformation à
force de se fragment
er la société se
trouve tué de blocs juxtaposés
d'identité ou d'options entre lesquelles
la communication est rompue alors
peut-on encore réenchanter le débat
public oui d'après vous mais il y a
urgence face au tumulte du monde
réchauffement climatique conflit armés
question d'égalité et de genre parmi vos
remèdes inclure davantage les citoyens
dans les décisions politiques au
réélection mais aussi et surtout savoir
se remettre en cause accepter les
opinions de chacun des prescriptions
mais ce soir Guillaume Prigent et
Bertrand Perrier nous avons une question
pour vous trouvez-vous que nos députés
sont de bons débatteurs messieurs à vous
le débat
bonsoir Bertrand Perrier bonsoir plaisir
de vous recevoir sur ce plateau à
nouveau et bienvenue à vous Guillaume
Prigent bonsoir bonsoir à vous alors
réponse pour commencer puisque débattre
si c'est comme vous l'écrivez savoir
écouter l'autre humblement le
reconnaître apprendre à ne pas être
d'accord
parfois même changer d'avis est-ce que
nos députés sont de bons débatteurs à
vos yeux evidemment les mississiques et
le lieu iconique du débat politique il y
a eu dans cette hémicycle les plus
grands débats les plus beaux discours la
peine de mort livrée les discours sur
l'Union européenne il y a quand même des
grands moments d'histoire du débat
parlementaire
parfois on a l'impression que en réalité
ce qui est recherché dans le débat y
compris parlementaire c'est la petite
phrase c'est l'agressivité et que en
réalité les députés ont en tête non pas
la situation dans laquelle il débattent
c'est-à-dire un débat parlementaire mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire sur un
réseau social qu'est-ce qu'on va en dire
dehors et c'est là que en effet parfois
le vert est dans le fruit alors
justement peut-être que le vert est dans
le fruit parce que c'est débats sont
filmés et donc on ne s'adresse pas
forcément à un parlementaire du camp
d'en face mais aux Français qui
regardent est-ce que Guillaume Prigent
sa fausse le jeu du débat du bon débat
ça le complique en tout cas ça le
complique beaucoup et plus on est
regardé plus il va être difficile
surtout si on est porté par ses troupes
ou soutenu par ses militants qui
poussent dans un sens plus ça va être
compliqué de faire marche arrière après
on peut filmer garder un très haut
niveau de qualité je pense aux
commissions d'enquête je pense aux
commissions d'information qui sont
filmées aussi et vous le faites donc
très bien et on voit que quand le patron
de Total quand le patron de par exemple
d'orpa vient de s'expliquer c'est des
débats compliqués des débats très
difficiles mais les débat arrive à se
faire malgré la caméra mais peut-être
parce qu'on dit justement on met un
tiers il y a un président de comique de
chambre qui égalise les débats qui
s'assurent que la parole est verrouillée
bref il y avait quand même des petits
cadres qui permettent d'éviter que le
débat ne prenne toute la place alors
comment nous reparler finalement parle
ment parler mais débattre est-ce que
c'est seulement ce parler c'est déjà
s'écouter aussi c'est pas seulement se
parler c'est accepter d'avoir tort vous
savez grosso modo pour un bon débat il
faut trois conditions il faut du temps
de l'expertise et de la bonne foi si on
n'a pas ces trois piliers là on peut pas
débattre raisonnablement ou alors on
débat de façon purement factice
c'est-à-dire un débat dans lequel on
connaît déjà le résultat or précisément
c'est là que le fait majoritaire à
l'Assemblée nationale rend les choses un
peu plus délicates parce que souvent on
a un débat mais on sait que la majorité
politique
l'issue de ce débat alors les choses ont
un petit peu changé avec la nouvelle
donne politique mais c'est vrai que même
là on l'a vu avec notre précédent débat
il y a du théâtre dans un jeu de dupes
écrit à l'avance sans suspense pour
autant peut-être que cette majorité
relative est de l'occasion de restaurer
le débat des séries de créer des
majorités d'idées non pas des majorités
mécaniques des majorités que l'on
conquier et que l'on construit et c'est
peut-être paradoxalement aussi une une
chance pour l'assemblée d'avoir un vrai
rôle d'élaboration de la norme et non
pas seulement d'enregistrement alors
votre livre à tous les deux Guillaume
Prigent par d'un constat passé un peu
inaperçu la disparition du débat la
grande revue de Marcel Gauchet en
septembre 2020 et vous y voyez d'une
certaine manière le symbole de la
disparition du débat que vous aimez à
proprement parler dans l'espace public
comme s'il était devenu stérile et
inutile comment on en est arrivé là ça a
pris beaucoup de temps pour en arriver
là il a fallu que sorte du jeu de la du
débat ça tombe d'acteur il a fallu que
une certaine experts ne disent je n'y
vais plus parce que je n'ai pas le temps
de parler je n'ai pas le temps d'être
tranquille écoutez ou entendu je me
retire et on voit apparaître sur le
climat par exemple des gens qui sont
platistiques ou qui racontent des choses
qui sont complètement absurdes parce que
les gens du Gex se replient on veut pas
subir ça il faut que le politique
parfois se dise je n'y arrive pas et que
vient d'apparaître à sa place des gens
qui sont peut-être plus militants mais
qui n'ont pas solution concrète à
proposer parce que politique lui dit moi
ma solution elle prend du temps à
expliquer elle est complexe à mettre en
œuvre et si vous dites en 3 minutes
comment est-ce que je fais pour faire ça
je ne peux pas vous le faire et donc se
retire du débat des gens et ce sera la
même chose qu'on se retire du débat des
gens cet espace la nature a horreur du
vide donc il faut combler ce vide et
celui qui va être comblé par des
personnes qui sont pas forcément de
bonne foi et qui viennent plus dans le
débat pour chercher une image pour eux
ou pour leur camp pas du tout pour
trouver une solution pas du tout pour
débattre avec autrui vous montrez bien
comment les réseaux sociaux ne sont pas
au fond un lieu de débat même si on dit
souvent l'Agora des réseaux sociaux on
s'adresse à des gens qui pensent déjà
comme soi dans une forme de d'entre soi
de tunnel il y a un avertissement dans
ce livre si le débat n'est pas comment
dire possible alors la violence va
surgir oui les réseaux sociaux c'est
fascinant parce qu'il y a toutes ces
biais cognitifs c'est bulles
informationsnel où on est entretenu par
les algorithmes dans des convictions que
l'on a déjà et on vit dans des cercles
qui pensent comme nous et donc en fait
on n'a pas de contradiction le débat
c'est d'abord reconnaître l'autre comme
mon égal accepter de l'écouter
reconnaître la légitimité de sa parole
et aussi et c'est ce que Guillaume
disait échanger avec honnêteté des
vérités à partir du moment où on ne
cherche plus la vérité ou on admet des
postes vérités on admet des fake news le
débat n'est plus possible
Bertrand Périer et Guillaume Prigent les
réseaux sociaux c'est aussi des endroits
où les gens disent là j'ai le droit de
m'exprimer le débat c'est pas pour moi
il m'a été confisqué j'en étais exclu au
moins sur les réseaux on m'écoute je
peux parler j'ai un droit de parler et
c'est un peu illusoire aussi cela parce
que vous dites effectivement qu'il n'y a
pas de barrière à l'entrée c'est vrai
techniquement tout le monde peut ouvrir
un compte sur Twitter et s'exprimer
librement même si le droit aussi à son
mot à dire sur ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ne sont pas des
zones de non-droits en dépit de
l'anonymat qui iraient mais il y a aussi
d'autres hiérarchies qui règnent sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est la hiérarchie des
followers et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant de voir le terme de follower
on suit quelqu'un on ne débat pas on
suit quelqu'un et donc on se crée des
communautés et finalement ce qui fait la
force d'un message sur sur Twitter ça
n'est pas l'expertise de celui qui le
dit c'est son nombre de followers alors
quelle solution parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup esquissé dans dans le livre
pour apprendre à se reparler au fond
c'est faire l'inverse de ce que vous
décrivez comme vraiment le contre à ne
pas suivre on se souvient de Paul Amar
on a pas le temps de vous remettre
l'archive mais peut-être qu'on peut
l'avoir en illustration Paul Amar qui
offre des gants de boxes on s'en
souvient tous sur ce plateau du journal
télévisé à Bernard Tapie et et à
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est tout le
contraire de ce qu'il faut faire quelle
solution possible Guillaume Prigent il y
en a plusieurs mais il y en a une qui
doit être la plus essentielle c'est
l'école il y a une il y a une phrase que
je trouve magnifique de Danton dans son
discours sur l'éducation il dit après le
pain l'éducation et le premier besoin du
peuple dit autrement si on ne donne pas
des armes à des citoyens si on ne
considère qu'un citoyen se fait tout
seul on va droit dans le mur et on va
retourner dans la monarchie et c'est ce
qui va se passer d'ailleurs quelques
décennies plus tard donc il avait pas
tort et de dire on va apprendre à lire à
écrire raconter mais un citoyen ça doit
débattre un citoyen ça doit apprendre
l'art de discuter avec autrui et ça
s'apprend dès le plus jeune âge les de
Saxon le fond qu'on se connaille en
Nouvelle-Zélande au Canada aux
États-Unis en Angleterre dès le plus
jeune âge il y a des systèmes on donne
un bâton de parole et on veut que les
apprend à les élèves apprennent à se
parler les uns avec les autres qu'ils
acceptent d'écouter une parole qu'il
n'aime pas pendant une minute deux
minutes s'il le faut et avant de dire
non je ne suis pas d'accord et quand on
dit non de dire pourquoi tu n'es pas
d'accord tu peux pas juste te dire je
vais d'accord je veux pas l'entendre
quelle est la raison que tu apportes
quel est l'exemple que tu donnes et si
tu n'as pas ça tu n'as participation au
débat est plus et plus pauvre il y a
1000 manières de faire le top donc ça
prend du temps et ça demande de former
un stand de évidemment de mon enseignant
à ce jeu là quelle formation comment
comment on apprend à bien débattre vous
avez une sorte de va d'aimer comme il y
a pas de débat d'abord si on est on est
d'accord mais en même temps il y a pas
de débat si on se respecte pas volonté
de convaincre éthique de la persuasion
incertitude de l'issue est nécessité
d'agir ça veut dire qu'à la fin il faut
prendre une décision oui le débat c'est
pas une conversation de salon sinon on
fait ça autour de la table dominical le
débat ce qui est intéressant c'est
précisément que il doit précéder
l'action et donc le débat permet à la
décision d'être plus informé et plus
légitime on le voit bien parfois les
députés prennent des décisions vote des
lois dans la précipitation de
l'actualité notamment les faits divers
et la volonté politique de telle ou
telle d'imprimer son nom dans l'histoire
et puis après vous vous apercevez soit
que le Conseil constitutionnel va
censurer la loi soit que à l'usage elle
ne marche pas et donc on a l'impression
parfois d'une précipitation que le débat
permettrait en effet de contrecarrer
d'une trahison le débat citoyen sur le
climat ou ses citoyens avaient été
formés la plupart d'entre eux peut être
pas tous mais ont eu l'impression que
finalement il n'avait servi à rien parce
que les propositions n'avaient pas été
reprises
par un affichage de on fait appel moi je
ne crois pas du tout à l'idée que la
démocratie participative consisterait à
demander à tout le monde son avis sur
tout je ne crois pas du tout à cette
idée je crois que ça c'est important la
démocratie participative mais ça
consiste à permettre de s'exprimer à des
citoyens qui sont réformer qui sont
concernés et qui sont volontaires c'est
assez conditions là qu'on a eu un vrai
débat sinon il faut former les citoyens
un peu sur n'importe qui qui n'a pas
forcément envie qui n'a pas forcément
envie s'investir et ça ne fonctionne pas
comment nous reparler débattre Bertrand
Perrier Guillaume Prigent vous
reviendrez avec cette bateaux merci
infiniment c'est à dire aux éditions
Flammarion je vais vous garder encore
quelques secondes si vous le permettez
vers 30 périody avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix le mot de la semaine ce soir
choisi par Mariette darrigran c'est le
mot colère les archives de Brandon
warrett sur les grands débats de censure
restés dans l'histoire et puis on
l'accueille également Mathieu ozano du
shift project Mathieu qui nous parle de
cette météo plus clémente que prévu et
si sur le gaz et l'électricité cette
météo nous prémunissait de coupure cet
hiver nous affranchis les voici bonsoir
à vous trois plaisirs de vous retrouver
ce vendredi Mariette le mot de la
semaine la colère le mouvement social
manifestation grève dans les raffineries
et peut-être même dans les transports
pour le départ en vacances qui qui
s'annonce colère donc ce soir voilà
colère sociale un colère individuel d'un
futur retraité que l'air collective des
travailleurs qui s'appauvrissent etc
elle court elle court la colère dans
notre doux pays comme la maladie d'amour
d'antan mais alors pas du tout avec le
même effet donc la France n'est plus
amoureuse elle est râleuse voire
haineuse nous dit la semiologue que vous
êtes en tout cas elle est de mauvaise
humeur et je prends ce terme d'humeur au
sens de la d'Hippocrate de la médecine
des humeurs c'est à dire vous savez la
théorie des tempéraments des cas de
tempérament vous allez voir que ça a des
résonances avec nos typologies
politiques parce que premier tempérament
il est sanguin ça va ça marche on voit à
peu près le deuxième tempérament il est
flagmatique et là il devient indifférent
il arrête de voter si vous pouvez si on
peut dire le mélancolique bah c'est
celui qui a des problèmes de santé
mentale qui dépriment et le quatrième et
le quatrième la colère voilà le
quatrième qui nous intéresse on se fait
le colérique c'est le colérique alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on dit colérique ben
parce que il a trop de coller et la
coller c'était la bile dans la médecine
antique donc c'était vous savez c'est
jaune ça sort comme ça et puis aussi
peut-être parce qu'il se fait de la bile
au sens il s'inquiète pour son avenir
lui-même ou celui de ses enfants alors
ce qui m'intéresse là comme observatrice
c'est le succès de ce mot comment il a
irradi absolument tout le champ
politique c'est pas un mot de la langue
politique mais il est partout et il
permet d'agréger si vous voulez des
symptômes économiques sociaux féministes
que sais-je sous une sorte de même méta
concept qui veut pas dire grand chose
mais ça permet de réunir des gens qui ne
défileraient pas sous la même bannière
syndicale ou même qui ne serait pas au
même endroit de l'hémicycle donc c'est
un sentiment universel voilà c'est
universel on pourrait dire d'ailleurs
Trump par exemple a souvent dit qu'il
était angry et puis George c'est à
Meloni elle parle de sa Rabia etc donc
c'est universel en ce sens là parce que
en fait c'est anthropologique c'est dans
l'être humain et le philosophe de
l'imagination Gaston Bachelard avait une
formule géniale il disait l'homme est
une colère a priori donc oui c'est en
nous mais la question c'est que
qu'est-ce que ça vient faire dans le
politique le politique on pourrait dire
c'est l'inverse justement à cause de la
parole et de la valeur de la parole et
d'aider normalement donc voilà moi ce
qui m'inquiète beaucoup avec ça je me
mets en colère parce que c'est pas mon
tempérament non pas vraiment c'est sûr
oui mais par contre ça me met d'une
certaine humeur inquiète parce que je
pense que nous avons un gros risque
aujourd'hui de régresser à quelque chose
qui finalement va accréditer la violence
est-ce que nos politiques parfois vont
même jusqu'à susciter cette colère qui
est en nous ce que je trouve très
intéressant c'est que on a parlé de
l'hystérisation du débat sur les réseaux
sociaux tout à l'heure et il y a une
étude qui a été faite sur le réseau
waybo qui est l'équivalent chinois de
Twitter et qui a montré que les messages
qui avaient le plus de viralité qui
était retweeté qui était commenté qui
était liké était ce qui comportaient
l'émoticone colère et donc c'est
intéressant parce que en fait la colère
est sur représentée elle est surjouée si
vous avez un sourire votre votre message
n'a aucune chance de passer la barre de
la viralité et donc il y a une sorte de
prime à la colère dans les algorithmes
des réseaux sociaux qui fait que la
colère est sur représentée surjoué sur
valorisée internet de la haine c'est
bien montrer alors Bandon on va parler
d'émotions de censure il y a deux débats
de censure lundi que vous pourrez suivre
en direct sur LCP après la colère la
censure si j'ose dire c'est une motion
déposée par la nupes contre le 49-3
numéro 1 sur le budget puis une autre
déposé par le rassemblement national des
bas de censure alors c'est un grand
classique vous avez ouvert le placard à
archives exactement 115 motion de
censions ont été déposées depuis le
début de la 5e République en 1958 et
parmi elles une seule a fait mouche
c'était en 1962 les parlementaires
étaient opposés à l'élection du
Président de la République au suffrage
universel voulu par le général de Gaulle
jusque là le chef de l'État était élu
par un collège de 80 000 grands
électeurs parmi les députés socialiste
conseiller municipaux alors forcément
pour les députés ce changement ce n'est
pas maintenant il contre-attaque avec
une motion de censure pour renverser le
gouvernement Pompidou et à la tribune le
vieux briscard Paul Reynaud a un message
personnel pour le général de Gaulle
c'est la République qui répond non à
votre projet car le scrutin aujourd'hui
contrat dans l'histoire
pendant longtemps
on dira demain politique comment a-t-il
voté le 4 octobre
c'est notre honneur de parlementaire qui
est en cause
on ne se lasse pas du tout du verbe de
Paul Reynaud la Mosson censure sera
adoptée à la majorité absolue le Premier
ministre Pompidou et son gouvernement
sont renversés mais le président de
Gaulle dissout l'Assemblée les répliques
rapidement dans la foulée l'égo liste
remporte les nouvelles élections
législatives de Gaulle ressort avec une
majorité élargie et à Matignon en
Pompidou lui et conforté alors parfois
ça passe pas très loin 1989 il s'en est
fallu très peu pour renverser le
gouvernement de peu mais des débats où
le une Assemblée nationale en pleine
ébullition sur un projet de loi sur les
conditions de séjour et d'entrée des
immigrés en France les députés RPR et
UDF déposent une motion de censure mais
c'est des bas sont aussi l'occasion pour
le président du RPR Jacques Chirac de
revenir sur le devant de la scène un an
après son échec à la présidentielle de
1988 et en ligne de mire le député de la
Corrèze a une un seul et unis une seule
et unique cible dans cette affaire la
responsabilité de Monsieur Mitterrand
est entière il a entendu seul
imposer à tous une conception
personnelle de la situation des
étrangers en France
nous sont sur rejetés pour 25 voix
seulement et trois ans plus tard alors
c'est encore plus serré qu'on ne
l'imaginait 1992 Myriam les députés
secrètent le chignon sur un projet de
loi sur la politique agricole défendue
par le gouvernement socialiste alors que
le président Mitterrand ne dispose que
d'une majorité relative à l'Assemblée le
gouvernement doute alors le premier
ministre Pierre Bérégovoy joue sa
dernière carte la persuasion je sais que
les échéances de 1993 font rêver
certains
d'autres sont peut-être
allaient rapprocher
puis-je me permettre
un conseil
modeste conseil la précipitation
est mauvaise inspiratrice
la droite et le sang de voteront la
censure avec l'appui des communistes ça
c'est rare mais cela ne suffit pas 286
voix sur 289 nécessaires trois députés
n'ont pas suivi la consigne parmi eux
l'ancien Premier ministre Raymond Barre
et à noter un incident inédit aussi
l'ancien ministre de l'Information
député RPR à l'imperfit devait prendre
pas au vote mais au dernier moment il
s'est trompé il n'a pas voté Bertrand
Perrier débat là encore ce mot là de
censure débattre posture oui
inévitablement on joue un peu à se faire
peur en sachant à peu près l'issue ce
qui est intéressant je trouve c'est
comment la motion de censure est aussi
un évitement du débat c'est à dire que
on va voter un texte sans le débattre et
c'est évidemment toujours c'est aussi
l'action entre la nécessité du débat et
malgré tout la nécessité de l'efficacité
et de l'action politique et donc bien
sûr qu'il faut débattre aussi un moment
il faut trancher et donc pour ne pas
débattre du budget on va débattre d'une
motion de censure
et donc il y a une sorte de déplacement
et d'évitement du débat au bénéfice de
l'action ce qui n'est pas non plus
absurde on est quand même dans une
action politique le débat n'est pas une
fin en soi en tout cas c'est à suivre
ces différents débats de censure lundi
je vous lis alors peu de suspense de
motions distinctes donc aucune chance
d'être adoptée rester tranquille le
gouvernement ne sera pas renversé en
tout cas pas ce weekend donc enfin pas
lundi Matthieu bonsoir plaisir de vous
retrouver du shift project avec
Jean-Marc Jancovici alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un peu plus
d'après les prévisions du chez project
ou peut-être parce qu'on connaît cette
météo plus clémente finalement on
pouvait s'y attendre qu'est-ce qui va se
passer cet hiver est-ce qu'on aura moins
froid et donc moins de risque de coupure
de gaz et d'électricité
on a pas encore besoin de rouler donc on
a un automne qui est anormalement froid
on est très au-dessus des normes et pour
l'instant on a un certain répit sur
et on a on a un répit sur les prix du
gaz donc c'est un paradoxe qui est qui
est assez intéressant on redoue d'avoir
froid cet hiver et le réchauffement
climatique vient nous donner une espèce
de sursis en limitant les besoins de
l'électricité alors pour ce qui est de
cet hiver à la fois RTE et GRTgaz qui
gère respectivement les réseaux
d'électricité et de gaz nous disent que
si on met on
oeuvrement tout devrait tout devrait
bien se passer on devrait pas avoir
besoin de coupure la question c'est de
savoir si les Français vont être
suffisamment dociles et respectueux de
ce qui de ce qui a été préconisé parce
que l'essentiel des mesures sont
pas obligations pas de contraintes on
vous dit c'est bien de mettre à 19 le
chauffage pas plus mais il ne se passera
rien si vous ne le faites pas s'il doit
y avoir des coupures alors le
gouvernement utilise ce mot de délestage
comment ça va se passer
un gaz ou d’électricité alors les
préfets sont en train de terminer des
listes de de
ressources essentielles qu'il faut
préserver et dont auquel on ne coupera
ni l'énergie électrique ni le gaz après
il y a des outils en ligne qui font
regarder et coat et co gaz qui vont vous
permettre d'anticiper sur des tensions
et d'adapter
d'adapter votre consommation mais si
malgré tout des coupures sont
nécessaires les déstaches seront
tournants par zone géographique et
devraient pas durer plus de deux heures
par jour mais de toute façon si on a un
hiver froid ou même très froid c'est le
secrétaire du du comité social et
économique d'EDF qui a prévenu d'ores et
déjà que des coupures d'électricité
seront inévitables
hiver anormalement chaud alors ça
devrait nous prévenir de tout ça non et
oui mais alors c'est pas parce qu'on a
chaud maintenant que en janvier ou en
février il fera également chaud vous
savez on parle de réchauffement
climatique mais on peut tout aussi bien
parler de dérèglement climatique et là
les les instituts météorologiques sont
en train de regarder faire des
statistiques des probabilités et il est
pas impossible qu'on ait un hiver
particulièrement froid avec
en tout cas plus froid que ces dernières
années avec des conditions anticipées
avec de l'air froid qui viendra de
Russie et des éoliennes qui tourneront
pas parce qu'il y aura pas beaucoup de
vent ce qui est propre des conditions
anticycloniques en cas d'hiver rigoureux
seront les industriels pour les coupures
c'est ça
ça pose une question qui qui va bien
au-delà de cet hiver parce que en fait
les industriels mais pas qu'en France en
Europe sont déjà sous pression avec des
ralentissements voire des arrêts
d'activités il faut bien comprendre ce
qui se passe en fait au-delà de cet
hiver c'est pas juste l'industrie
française ni même l'industrie européenne
c'est toutes l'économie européenne qui
se retrouve dans la nasse
la perspective de devoir se passer de
tout ou partie du gaz russe pour les
années qui viennent va mettre l'économie
européenne
contrainte d'approvisionnement
d'approvisionnement dans cette énergie
abondante et pas chère sur laquelle
repose tout simplement tout notre toute
notre économie et donc toute la société
ce qui se passe c'est pas seulement
c'est pas juste une crise une crise
conjoncturelle dans un autre logiciel un
nouveau retournement de marée en fait
c'est un retournement de mariée c'est
c'est un changement d'époque on efface
en plus du climat une région une raison
supplémentaire de de mettre en oeuvre
enfin sérieusement la sortie des
énergies fossiles et Alexandre sobot qui
préside France industrie la bien résumé
dans un entretien aux échos il y a
quelques jours il a il a dit le déclin
industriel de l'Europe est inéluctable
inéluctable sans énergie décarbonée
compétitive et du reste aujourd'hui même
Elisabeth borne a parlé d'une époque
d'une question de survie une question de
survie donc voilà c'est historique et on
est dos au mur merci merci de
l'avertissement les mots pour que tout
soit compris et que il y a un civisme au
rendez-vous sont fondamentaux on entend
voilà survie on entend pied du mur il va
falloir la voir se débat sereinement
pour embarquer le pays oui c'est un
débat compliqué parce que c'est un débat
sur lequel Harry Potter il est politique
sont dans la dépendance des
scientifiques et donc l'argument
d'autorité devient quelque chose
d'absolument essentiel on peut avoir des
débats de toutes sortes on peut dire
qu'il faut différer mais tout ça est
toujours dans la dépendance de constat
scientifique que nous ne maîtrisons pas
mais pour le coup c'est un très beau
débat parce que précisément il est vital
et que la décision est absolument
nécessaire et ça c'est vraiment des
conditions pour un bon débat c'est qu'il
soit nécessaire et précédé de la et qui
précède l'action
comment en tout cas c'est débat merci
merci les affranchis à bientôt Mathieu
aux anneaux je rappelle le titre de
votre livre Bertrand Perrier avec
Guillaume Prigent qui est avec nous il y
a un instant débattre comment nous
reparler avec la Marion merci Brandon
merci Mariette c'est le week-end
profitez bien ça vous regarde bien mardi
prochain
[Musique]